you
everyone is cherrymon lead chess right
now and I just got paired up a 15-2 game
so let's see how this plays out try
Knight f3 as a start hmm c4 d4 I guess
we'll go at c4 retain some flexibility
with that deep on that will often change
up the opening committing that deep on
so C pawn first let's go with let's go
with the Knight c3 on d5 I'll take and
then after Knight takes I'll play e4 not
going for that though okay let's see d4
or efore efore will prevent the d4 d5
advance let's do that or maybe not
let's see what other options might I
have I could go with g3 mmm g 3g 3 d 4e
4 or my candidate moves here I'm just a
little bit concerned if I play e4 this
move c5 I could still get in d4 we'll
enter a peroxy bind yeah that that's
that's fine might transition into a a
Sicilian here depending on Black's next
move okay now so there C pawn will not
be able to exchange itself off for my
deep on so easily
group of three pawns now in the center
and probably just Bishop to e2 let's see
and the other good options I don't want
to obstruct my Queens view of d4 this is
something that's really going to be
struck out either c v e5 Knight c6
maybe so I'm pretty sure in other words
I know where my LightSquared Bishop
belongs so let's get him there Bishop to
e2 this is also useful depending on if
black does here of course this 'if I've
d5 reply if I move my knight out of the
way it'll stop a knight pivot sometimes
I want to go there to then jump into f4
but okay we have Knight c6 hmm okay my
first thought is to just give them a
quick kick here with d5 sore anything
wrong with that
let's give them a kick is he gonna go to
e5 I think I've had players do this
against me before playing to this square
I mean they're doubled pawns and know
how big of an issue it is but I like
that my bishop is able to see these
squares after I do capture mm-hmm so
they are going in that direction my
first thought is just to take it makes
their Bishop on g7 not the greatest
piece in the world
yeah probably just take I'm inviting
this pawn a little bit more forward but
it is a doubled upon now and in what
direction is this game going to go this
question I have
I should probably castle Bishop to e3
mm-hmm can I do without castle
no let's do that first remain a little
bit more flexible with my bishop maybe
he'll go to g5 I guess these are the two
Candida moves I don't think I'll invest
any time with fee and kettering okay
well that's a that was a move that was
played really quick and I have the
option now to take and damage their
Queen side and I'll
I could now look forward to an ending
and in ending I think I'll be the better
side here because I don't really see how
this bishop will be getting involved
anytime soon so hmm
I'm pretty much going to take here I'm
just double-checking stuff yeah I don't
want to allow it to be closed either
like this night reposition this could be
a fine home for the night
I think I should look to open it up and
in some sense play against their poorly
placed minor piece on g7 after takes
recapture I don't know if I'll take
their queen because I am helping out
their rook but I think I could say for
certain I want to take like this I'd
certainly welcome Queen takes Queen by
them so now the decision to take their
queen or not hmm if I play Bishop to e3
where's their queen really even going to
go I always have this knight jumping
into these squares now that these pawns
are split or I you know they're isolated
so the squares in front of them are
probably good homes for pieces Knight
might want to arrive on c5 this is a
king side specific bishop dark square
bishop so he won't be around to watch
over these Queen side dark squares so
easily after Queen takes Queen rook
takes Queen then Bishop to e3 and we're
heading towards Queen side specific play
not sure what
to consider here queen a4 pressure on c6
and then I could be gaining a tempo with
rook to d1 hmm I feel like I should be
starting with Bishop to e3 one thing I
want to make sure of is that this Knight
does not get to d4 any time soon it'll
take forever it's night two squares away
diagonally from takes them a while to
get there
what other candidate moves do I have
Bishop to e3 Queen takes Queen and then
Bishop to e3 I think I kind of like just
getting the Queen's off first
yeah let's mmm maybe not honey got let's
go hard like I couldn't resist couldn't
resist alright so on Bishop e3 Knight
here I could reply bishop here or maybe
even take and then you know this is my
bad Bishop after all so let's start with
this this is also useful in putting
pressure here so this might having this
pressure on a7 may translate into me
obtaining control over this only open
file because it's placing a restriction
on the rook any pressure against my B
panel play b3 and there isn't this idea
of breaking down in a 2 B 3 C 4
structure because this is a nice pivot
for my knight on a form so let's see
what black comes up with they're kind of
a hard-pressed to find a good square for
their light square bishop you know if
you go here not sure what you're doing
exactly this isn't an inconvenience to
put pressure on my c4 pawn
they might try to activate their Bishop
here but again it the big question here
in my eyes at least is what exactly is
this Bishop going to do so they're
looking for a knight reposition and as
mentioned I may be able to now obtain
control over this D file this seems
correct and I want to go with this rook
I don't know if it makes so big a deal
but I want to have a fast track over
here with my king and I'm able to know
when upon am I not hmm
so let's see here I take that rook they
take back I take on a seven they enter
on d2 is that really so much a problem I
mean I'll have to defend for just a
moment you know we're up to it rook to
b1 or here but I think I'd play rook to
b1 and then on my next move I could come
back here but maybe they caused me a
little bit of a problem with that
because of move like Bishop to h6 and
that's what sure I want to allow that
activity what would they do if I don't
allow them to have full control over the
D file you know suppose I play King f1
King e1 and then threatened to take here
first of all where's this night going he
goes here I play b3 there might be then
the follow-up of this advance but I
don't know if that really scares me so
much my instinct tells me to just
improve my king position a little bit
more night here to here is also an idea
hmm maybe I should improve my piece and
maybe I should be a bit more direct
although no a Knight to a4 96 and these
two pawns are hit
okay so not so fast let's improve my
king position King King f1 King f1 King
e1 then they'll have to do something for
sure about the right pond on 96 uh plate
B 396 b3 and on f5 I'll play f3 it may
happen that there's an exchange here but
if the F pond is exchange for my e pond
that'll result in them having a double
isolated pond and in a position where
it's just the bishops that's gonna be
and that's so good well it really
doesn't matter no matter how you slice
it these two double isolated ponds are
glaring weakness so let me consider we
get again capturing on d8 and then a7
should I do that I mean I will have a
passed a pond sure the computer would be
all over that I'm not going to do it
though okay now they have to certainly
tend to this threat of exchanging rooks
and then capturing on a7 so and when
they move their pawn to a5 I can think
about the b6 square not only c5 anymore
but but also be six maybe even bit
should be six in some cases but I'll
probably need to play b3 first also if
there's a if they're a pawn moves I
think I'll first play f3 just to
reinforce this pun and that way my
knight could move without fear of Knight
d6 hitting both of these and it's
difficult I mean I'm not quite sure what
the bishop is doing on fa9 I know it
wants to come out in this direction but
so many things need to happen like this
Bishop has to move for starters and then
the pond okay so they're giving up
control of the d5
I can't enter on it but the rook is
restricted this Avon has to move before
the rook could move well I mean the rook
of play here but on any rook move to the
B file I'm playing b3 rook b8 ba b3 okay
they're striking in the center let's
reinforce that point oh the night might
also come to f6 I didn't consider that
but it shouldn't be a big deal okay
they're closing the position up hmm I
don't think that that's a good option
but alright let's stay here I don't want
to go to this square I'll leave that
option open for my knight so I don't
have any concern about this and now in
order for this bishop to become
activated it's clear that this pond
needs to move and it's very difficult
because if he goes here and then pushes
then it's the light-square bishop who
becomes bad hmm I didn't mention this
much I've been talking about pivoting on
this square with a knight but maybe this
move is an idea as well this isn't a
threat let's improve my knight position
I think he's going to be a great bother
on the c5 square hitting the light
square bishop yeah nice c5 and on Bishop
to c8 I could play rook here it could be
quite annoying probably just protect to
pick up the pace just a little bit here
five minutes and change okay
hey interesting night c5 Bishop back how
do I make more progress hc5 Bishop back
knight d3 Bishop g7 and then Knight here
let's try that let's try to induce some
weaknesses if I'm able to force my
opponent opponent Bishop to read treat
it like this I move forward I force my
opponent backward I've I've likely
obtained something something small but
you know I move forward I'm forcing them
backward they're not going backwards so
they're giving me the bishop hair Knight
takes King takes e5 and I could think
about giving this check this must be
correct I'm going to take that guy is
there anything better I'm gonna go for
that and then follow up with c5 I need
to activate my uh Bishop Bishop c4 it's
close to make there is that move but a
knight here I could even think about
taking I do have a majority I first I'm
referencing this but this is a healthy
three versus two majority on the Queen
side whereas they have an unhealthy King
side majority so I should probably
insert this check first inconvenience
their King and now consider taking the
night taking the knight and then playing
rook here or not taking the night at all
a little bit concerned
opposite color bishops a four-night here
hmm let's see hmm
rook d7 can I work around that night
yeah I mean it certainly has my
attention here this idea of giving some
material back a 494 takes rook takes and
then here hmm I really don't want to
give up my LightSquared bishop so easily
what other moves what I have here run
into a fork
ah riff d7 94 hmm let's take him to
activate this rook in in look to improve
my king position this rook is still tied
down I could also consider this you know
put pressure on this pawn King here I
just come over and he can't improve
further okay
still remains to be seen what is up with
that fish up how is he getting activated
let's play to a spot where I keep
pressure on my opponents pawns
maybe I don't prove like this I don't
want to over la route de 8 with check I
don't know how big a deal that would be
but at least for the moment moment hmm
maybe I should even do this remove first
stop g4 hey let me do that
it's difficult for them to improve it's
a useful move I could also look at this
position from the standpoint I have the
better bishop he has pawns fixed on dark
squares so I could maybe play a position
where I'm more focused on that you know
if the rooks are off and I somehow lose
this pawn it's probably a pretty easy
position to hold for a draw despite
being down upon if I again if I were if
I was to lose my C pawn it's very very
tough now I mean in order to activate
the bishop the King has to retreat he
has to move up move away I should say
from the action which is the excuse me
the Queen side of the board so as an
improvement if black is doing nothing
I'm playing King e2 King d3 they might
insert a Czech King here and they have
to be mindful of rook to b6 with Czech
picking up the a pawn if the rook
occupies this open file so let's see
what black comes up with they're
investing some time here they're in a
tough spot I don't know if I do well to
open up another file here I don't know
what exactly I accomplished by doing
that although maybe I grant my king
access to c4 by pulling the a4 move that
might be an idea and maybe maybe I
should not do this King II to move maybe
it's okay to cross on the D file first
and then get to the c-4 square as soon
as possible or the c3 square as soon as
possible and then do this move a4 yeah
let's see I could push but me
I'll push only after this pond has moved
hmm kingi to our king d2 is my uh he's
my candidate moves I'm gonna go here I
want to be just a hair closer towards
the Queen side King C three incoming a4
I think I want to do this first of these
two moves just to get out of checking
distance they might try to pile up on my
C pawn but I'll be there to play this
move okay and their King is now
completely cut out maybe a4 is the move
right now no I want to have this move
available let's do this activate my king
I might run all the way up here King
beef or maybe King b4 instead of before
hmm interesting moment King before but I
mean I am in a pin don't really like
that let's go before rook to b6 this
would be super passive if they do this
to defend laterally their King is cut
off under 2-minutes okay that's very
passive if I play rook here how are they
untangling let's do that first just to
stop here they might have tried wanted
to try that to undermine this structure
so
maybe King be three and a four is the
idea yeah let's do this they might try
to hunt down my bishop like one two
three my bishop is kind of no not really
I mean he could camp out here might not
be a bad square either come to think of
it putting pressure on e5 if they do
this I'm not I get out I'll take once
but not twice because King here that I'm
helping them activate their King so
they're in a tough spot I should follow
through and let's let's do this pressure
on the b-pawn improve my King position
now the King is still cut off the rook
is restricted and I'm looking to move
forward yet again with the b5 King takes
and then push I'm playing with all my
pieces in that resulting Physician King
rook Bishop and pawn their King is cut
off and the rook is passive along with
their Bishop I saw let's see what they
come up with here this is one of those
positions where he tried his white to
keep it as clean as possible
the rook is if he moves if he tries to
get activated I could take here if I
push here Bishop takes pawn is not where
because of pawn takes rook Bishop takes
rook Bishop takes Bishop where you from
pawn push so I think I just get on with
pushing I don't think I'm missing
anything I don't think I can make I have
to do this to make progress and I'm at a
minute so I'm just going to push away
here I might be close to sacrificing
here let's continue pushing on a rook
check on b8 I can block and I could also
welcome
a bishop exchange and you know if this
position is stripped of if it's just
King and pawn ending this is winning
again due to these uh these doubled
pawns here the EE pawns so now let's see
what our black comes up with the the big
plan here is to push and then King here
so let's just block I don't want to
allow that rook any activity and I'll be
pushing next King here so that this is
actually pretty much seeing the end to
this one their King isn't flying c7 King
c6 and then rook to b8 let's do that
first Bishop here King here and I'm King
there I could play Bishop here I don't
want to allow their King to get here
though you know they're not going
anywhere from that position though I
could I can improve a little bit more
let's see okay that's what they're
trying here so I can see six for
starters yeah King c6 here hmm
their king can't move their Bishop can't
move the rook is the only one that could
move thank you to this yeah less than 20
so now they're going to run out of moves
I think I could do this maybe a rook
back and then King here in rook here
stuff that might be an idea yeah
if I get my okay and I should I should
probably just let's take first take
again
less than 10 rook to g8 look to g8 I
play here okay I think I got it now
because they're forced to make a move if
they move their Bishop I'm going here as
soon as there's not as not to pieces
hitting c7 I could play rook here and
rook here what were I do maybe just push
my pawn keep these guys sitting right
where they're at my opponents in a bind
here they've been in a bind for a little
bit so I'm Rick eight I just push and on
that move I have this I'm pushing
through here though they're going for
that but he is protected to my bishop so
they might they might play it out just a
little bit more here now let's just
approach over here take let's take here
here and then I just take here and then
push next that's with check Capri move
and they'll probably resign here with
the increment or not might just play it
out to mate here so we'll see what the
computer has to say afterwards here is
courting this pawn avoiding any
stalemates stalemates and let's see get
the Queen and let's see see if we could
do this get the king and queen working
playing this without the bishop just
picturing it as if it's the king and
queen alone okay they resigned so let's
see let's just dive right in here going
to the analysis board
getting a computer analysis they
shouldn't take too long
and I think and that early middle game
decision to play into e5 and allowed
Knight takes Knight and playing with
those double D pawns probably not a good
idea I think I've seen I mean I've seen
that I've played against that in blitz
but I've had opponents on the black side
play that in blitz but never never
really in a standard game I think I've
even seen on that d5 pushed the knight
returned and then looked at pivot you
know on the d7 square so let's see
computers still thinking a little bit
here but yeah that's where I think
there's going to be a something
evaluation wise see a shift there so
this is just the quick scan I don't know
if we could let's see 95 yeah well first
off I mean Knight knight c6 if it should
be to knight c6 is really the main
problem because of d5 so something's
given up there and it was a slow and it
just got worse but let's see what some
of the suggestions are by the computer
here on the right hand side just kind of
well really doesn't even go into you
know some other suggestion besides
Knight to c6 here but you know there is
this main move of be 5 and then on d5 we
go we go in this direction where black
will be playing on the King side and I'm
going on the Queen side but uh they
didn't strike first in the center that
turned out to be a big problem takes I
mean where are there some other or is
there maybe another improvement this is
having it as a 0.7 point 8 advantage so
approaching you know it's it's just it
again a difficult road ahead I mean I'm
not sure what other options there are
I'm just holding this e for point if
they're ever taking these are then I
mean it remains they remain doubled
they're either going to be doubled as a
group or double isolated sour this is
just even worse giving exchanging I
mentioned it earlier if they're
exchanging their F pawn for my e pawn
these double isolated pawns let's yeah
can't be good
so what else mmm it's really difficult
to suggest something to be perfectly
honest here huh hmm I mean it's just a
growing advantage from this point Knight
c5 king f7 it's not pointing out some
other suggestion here I thought Bishop
back and I was planning Knight d3 and
they have to tend to this pawn bishop
here I'm not sure oh I think I said I
was going to consider this move Bishop
here is ruled out because of c5 and
Bishop here well now I could think about
entering with c5 and then rook here with
tempo so this this would be very
difficult to defend if if black did go
in this direction with this knee-jerk
reaction type move you know here boxing
the knight out from these advancing
squares very common Knight here and into
this square gaining a tempo here and
then hitting this pawn it's very very
difficult to defend the bishops nearly
well that could do it and the as
mentioned uh you know c5 c5 within a
rook invasion that's too much and you
got the bishop coming here with check
it's just crumbling
so maybe relatively best is what they
they did in the game here giving up the
Bishop improving their King position but
they were just sectioned off the King it
was either one of the other pieces I was
mentioning it earlier
about I think right around right around
here right around when they played
Bishop f8 I said well how are they
getting their Bishop on this you know
playing on this dog you know they'd have
to move their Bishop they're hard
pressed to find a good square other than
e6 for their Bishop and you know after
they did this move you know if if we
have this sort of thing and then flowing
up here it's the bishop that's bad it's
like one a one-piece will always remain
bad for black in this position one of
the two bishops as it turned out in the
game the King ended up being cut off so
the King was never really a great
contributor to the black position and
one of their bishops I was always bad
the dark square bishop he never really
got activated so just giving that check
first inconveniencing the King and this
allows me to enter no just for that one
moment notice if I didn't do that first
right I just take right away takes I
don't have d7 so inconvenience first and
then move forward with taking activate
the rook keep him activated and just
improving first one other detail I don't
know how big a deal it is but if I wants
to play let's say King D 2 instead of H
3 this could be my H pond is maybe a
little bit more vulnerable to I don't
know like a quick rook down here and
then capture if I have if I have this
pawn up here if there's ever this
exchange and another exchange here the
resulting base point f3 is an easier
point for me to defend then upon all the
way over here on H 2 which I don't know
how great if you know if it really is
likely to be an issue but that's you
know that's just like the quick thought
I thought I had you know if you are
going to get this break in there won't
be an H pawn
I won't have an H pun on the board that
you could even think about attacking and
I'll have an F pond which is a little
bit easier for me to defend with my king
ideally you want your king in the center
so if he could also be in the center and
conveniently defend f3 if should there
be pressure on f3 one day I'm better off
in that case so h3 first that's why I
don't think I was able to really voice
that during the game but it's just you
know that's what was going through my
mind so yeah and there's really very
little suggestion here I mean this is
this is already a winning position
because of you do you could go by
sectioning it off the King side and the
Queen side the Queen side I am playing
with an extra pawn a healthy majority
versus an unhealthy majority on the
Kings side and you could also do a piece
by piece comparison rook versus rook
King versus King Bishop versus Bishop
these guys are you know they're better
so I think again it's all it's coming
all the way back to that's you know I'm
sure there's of course more resistance
that could have been put up but that
decision to play Knight to c6 and play a
position where you have the double D
pawns I've I've seen it I've seen that
played but then the follow up of a quick
strike at the d5 pawn so let me just
point out one uh one additional thing
here I've seen that move before don't
know that it can be recommended but
Knight to c6 takes takes I've seen this
as a follow up that's what did I do next
I castled so after a castle instead of
c5 yeah instead of c5 the movie six and
at least you're exchanging one of the
doubled pawns off for this one here but
white will still be standing better due
to the space advantage and just having
it an easier time a bit more free pieces
and again it's still it's a still a big
question here with this pawn now
fixed on the e5 square what exactly is
he doing so even in situations like this
should this pond come up I just leave it
sitting and continue with developing if
it takes I take like this and now you
know I have a place for my rook but
anyhow interesting of interesting middle
game interesting night Stuart well it's
an early night c6 moving and I don't
know really can't probably that but
anyhow feel free to leave any comments
in the comment section below to this
video as usual I hope you got something
out of it and I'll catch you in the next
one that's all for now take care bye
you